wird betont dass die eltern sie fertig
gebacken aber wenn ich es nicht film
würde wäre das im zehn minuten takt
verkehren aus aber die optik ist
das
[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es einen
ganz ganz schnellen geburtstagskuchen
wenn ihr mal den geburtstag von euren
liebsten vergessen denn
ich muss es schnell irgendwas zaubern
aber keine zeit nicht habe keine
besonderen zutaten zu hause dann müsste
ich dranbleiben denn dieses rezept ist
genial wir machen nämlich ein boden dem
wir in der mikrowelle button und dann
ein superschnelles forsting um drauf und
am ende wird der beschenkte denken bord
dankeschön auch zu der um ihr gewicht
gegeben also wir starten jetzt mit dem
boden ich schreibe euch alle ganz
genauen mengenangaben unten infobox und
ich nehme zu allererst zimmer warme
butter solltet ihr keine zeit haben die
butter früh genug aus dem kühlschrank zu
nehmen dann könnt ihr sie auch einfach
bei ganz geringer war zahl für ein paar
sekunden die mikrowelle geben das ist
hier gar kein problem zur butter gebe
ich dann noch sogar natürlich und ganz
entscheidender geschmack ist warner
extrakt weil sonst muss ich sagen
schmeckt der boden sehr langweilig also
ihr braucht schon im geschmack wenn ihr
es zitronig haben möchtet gibt keine bio
zitrone abrieb mit dazu ich nehme hier
mein wanninger extrakt das ist jetzt
auch die verbesserte rezeptur also es
schmeckt noch intensiver ist es doppelt
soviel vanille drin wie vorher wir haben
ja echt monate lang getüftelt daher ist
dort auch gar nicht so viel und jetzt
verrückt ist eine minute lang und dann
gebe ich so allmählich milch mit dazu
joghurt und alle anderen zutaten
[Musik]
ich mag mehl und backpulver einfach nur
da zu gesiegt und ganz kurz untergerührt
dass er jetzt keine minute gedauert ok
eineinhalb minuten auf jeden fall habe
ich das jetzt fertig den teig und
breitet gefahr sie unsere mikrowellen
form vor und da funktioniert keine
springform ich hab's versucht das klappt
ich bin braucht er gar nicht versuchen
dies einfach zu dick dies nicht für die
mikrowelle geeignet ihr braucht einfach
nur ein kunststoff gefäß das eben in die
mikrowelle darf und das schreibe ich
euch den durchmesser in die infobox ihr
dürft auch mit dem durchmesser ein paar
zentimeter variieren ihr müsst dann halt
nur im blick behalten wann der teig
durch ist und dass er nicht zu trocken
jetzt machte auch nachher gerne stäbchen
probe aber zuallererst bereite ich meine
backpapier vor indem ich es immer wieder
knicke und wenn ihr dann nicht mehr
könnt mit dem kicken dann könntest was
ich hier so in die mitte halten von
eurer vormittags mal umgedreht dann
schneidet ihr quasi hier außen einfach
ab wenn ihr das dann eröffnet sie sollte
ein kreis entstehen und alles glatt
läuft bin gespannt
ja das sieht doch mal ganz gut aus jetzt
einfach die unten drunter es gibt glaube
ich ein bisschen back trance play auf
dem boden damit das auch schön an haupt-
und angriff damit was auch später gut
wieder raus bekommt dann fühle ich den
teig ein und dann war der teig zusammen
mit der form in die mikrowelle
[Musik]
ich hatte den boden jetzt bei 900 watt
für genau acht minuten in der mikrowelle
guckt gerne mal nach sieben minuten
vielleicht auch 90 minuten wichtig ist
dass ihr die stäbchen probe macht
einfach einen schaschlikspieß rein und
wenn nichts kleben bleibt dann ist der
boden entzieht sich auch nach dem backen
ein bisschen zusammen das heißt
eigentlich ist meine form 20 cm im
durchmesser aber es sind nur noch 19 was
ich jetzt so zusammen zieht das aber
ganz normal wir lassen ihn jetzt
auskühlen und machen in der zwischenzeit
das leckere vanille frosting dafür
brauchen wir auch nicht ganz wenige
zutaten ich habe hier mascarpone
mascarpone schmeckt so schön neutral da
gebe ich jetzt zum süßen puderzucker mit
dazu einfach direkt mit rein und für den
guten geschmack vanille extrakt und dann
verdünne ich das noch mit zum
schlückchen milch und rühre dass noch
ganz kurz und dann ist es forsting auch
schon fertig
[Musik]
so jetzt wird nur noch schnell
zusammengestellt habe jetzt hier einfach
ein skateboard da habe ich jetzt
entweder die schwarze seite oder die
goldene ich nehme aber die golden so zac
dann einmal das backpapier entfernen und
dann nehme ich mir einfach nur noch das
maske polo forsting und bestreicht das
rundherum und dann hab ich mir gedacht
mach ich wirklich nur noch so bunte
streusel wenn ich ein bisschen voraus
den übrig habt vielleicht noch ein paar
tupfer aber viel passiert jetzt nicht
mehr
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja dann okay du hast geburtstag drückt
diese torte frühling sei dass sie zum
beischlaf also im kind freut sich ein
mädchen frau ist auf jeden fall auch für
ältere darauf freut sich aber erfreut
sich
muss ich auch sagen dass ich aus dem
bericht dass aber das sieht das ist so
pink
da bin ich ziemlich
alles klar und ja ich bin gespannt
wie todes dass man sich geborgen und hab
auch mal andere gebracht dafür
jetzt bin ich super gespannt auf der
bohrinsel haare okay aber das ist kein
das ist kein normaler boden das ist
nicht das was von mir kennen 2 wenn ich
normalerweise backe ich noch ganz oft
wissen würden der südeifel häufig ist
man muss natürlich abstriche machen es
gibt schnell gebraucht wir nicht zu
taten es ist super easy aber ihr bekommt
natürlich kein super frostigen boden das
ist ja auch klar so ein paar ab ich
glaube dadurch dass wir filme waren 20
minuten aber wenn ich jetzt nicht film
würde wäre das mit zehn jahren sagt
wenders ohne viel zeit nimmt und es ist
kaum
vorstellbar vor allem wenn wir ganz oft
auch mit unseren mädels so kann man
jetzt auch noch eine überraschung und
wir und dann würde ich so was ganz
schnell machen wenn wir den boden noch
machen musst du musst ja erstmal
abkühlen lässt dass der preis stunde war
das ihr die hose sollte eier trennen da
ist nicht mal eine fixe boot nehmen wir
haben
wir fahren direkt in china und der ganze
kuchen schmeckt auch komplett nach
vanille also ich muss dann immer
weggelassen das zu langweilig aber die
optik ist das immer gleich das ist
wichtig wäre dass aus einem anderen
büchern moment
du kannst du wirst uns zu boden sind hat
das ist normal also das ist der abstrich
gemacht auch für mich selbst und
gegenseitig fest liga
in der mikrowelle gebracht werden kassel
- also es ist eigentlich auch so für
sowieso wenn man da wären begeistert
wenn ich habe gedacht vielleicht so
studenten die keinen ofen habe so oder
so aber verlor wenig weil ich dadurch
binden so bank da ich kann mir das nicht
gesagt ja ich kann sagen aber die
meisten wahrscheinlich können nicht so
gut backen die meisten jungs so ja schön
ganze familie jetzt sind all das frei
geredet dafür bildeten ja und noch in
orient angaben und videos genau an doch
freigesprochen oder konnten sich kontakt
gehalten
nachbarn und bis zum nächsten mal auf
die disketten teams
[Musik]